- You see the kids buggin'
you, he puts his hands on you,
you pick up the nearest rock
or whatever you can get your
hands and you lay him out.
- So you consider yourself lucky.
- Very lucky.
- But you have to have talent
to meet the luck, right?
- Somebody hands you the ball and you run.
So ambition was a dirty
word to me because it felt
like you were working for
some gain or material...
- He's widely regarded as one of
the world's biggest film stars.
He rose to prominence in his
role in a 1980's tv series,
21 Jump Street where he
quickly became a teen idol.
He was listed in the 2012
Guinness Book of World Records
as the highest paid actor
earning over 75 million dollars.
He's Johnny Depp and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And you guys know the
drill, if you hear something
that Johnny says that really
inspires you please leave it in
the comments below and
put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(pop music)
- If we could celebrate
every breath that we take,
because nothing's a guarantee.
If we can celebrate the
breath and the exhale,
which is, being alive, without you know,
"Oh my car won't start.
Oh geeze, you know,"
"the cat dropped dead."
(audience laughs)
"I think I need a lobotomy."
I mean, there are things
that are very very important
in life that we, we just, we
don't think about, you know?
And one of the most worrisome
things that I went through
for years, you're freaked
out about your past,
you're worried, you're scared
to death of the future,
and that's all you're thinking about.
And the now doesn't exist.
You know?
And I think that's a grave
mistake that we make.
One of the greatest pieces of advice
I've ever gotten in my
life was from my mom,
you know, when I was a little kid.
There was a kid that was
bugging me, you know, in school.
She said, "Okay, I'm going
to tell you what to do."
She said, "The kid's bugging
you, he puts his hands on you,"
"you pick up the nearest
rock, or whatever you can get"
"your hands on, and you lay him out."
And I did.
And I felt better.
And it worked.
So, for me, you know,
that was a great lesson,
cause someone had invaded
my space, invaded my being,
you know, and doing something
against me that I didn't
want to be done, so I took
control of the situation,
and I ran with it.
And, um, many years later,
after being, you know,
turned into a product, you know,
by a very huge corporation,
that had their hands all over me,
and I couldn't escape it, you know.
I promised myself that I would
continue to move forward,
and do my best not to compromise
in any way whatsoever,
you know, not allow anyone
to put their hands on me,
and affect me in that way.
So, that's the best
advice I think I can give,
is just to keep moving forward,
and don't give a shit
about what anybody thinks,
just keep moving forward,
and do what you have to do,
for you.
- Paul Newman told me that
any successful person,
in any field, who in
discussing their career,
doesn't use the word "luck" is a liar.
- Oh, yeah, he's absolutely right, yeah.
- So you consider yourself lucky.
- Very lucky, yeah.
- But you have to have talent
to meet the luck, right?
- If somebody hands you the
ball, and you run, you know,
and if you get hit, you get hit.
Or maybe you make it
through, you never know.
But I just know that
somebody handed me the ball
at a certain point,
and I was hungry enough to keep running.
And I'm still running.
I maintain the hunger,
but not an ambition.
You know, I'm very happy to
explore all possibilities
of a character, and really
dive in to the role,
I mean, to the point of where
Disney wanted to fire me.
- They wanted to fire you from Pirates?
- Yeah.
- Because?
- They couldn't understand
what I was doing.
They didn't understand the character.
They were actually contemplating
subtitling the film,
you know.
- And you went to play
music when you quit school,
you didn't go to become an actor.
- I had already started playing
the guitar at the age of 12,
I felt a passion for, yeah,
it was the first real passion
that I had.
And I can safely say because
I felt then that the word
ambition has become dirty. You know?
- Yeah.
- Because ambition somehow
implies that there is..
(baby cries)
I know.
I know, I know. Cry.
I'll probably be crying
in about 10 minutes.
So ambition's a dirty word to me,
because it felt like you
were working for some gain,
or some material, or some status, or,
so I literally don't remember
going through puberty,
because I locked myself in a
room at the age of 12, 12-13,
and just played the guitar,
and learned things off records,
and taught myself how to play.
And it was my life.
And it was the only solace,
it was the only sanctuary,
it was the only security,
it was my first love.
- At the end of our session yesterday,
you said, "Thank you to Scott
for reviving my career,"
- Yeah.
- And I don't know if that's in jest,
because I've never had
the impression that you,
you're desperate for Box Office.
- I'm begging for it.
It's been the thrust of
my interest since day one,
since I was about 19.
Yeah, that's all I care about.
20 years of failures will do that to you.
- But, on a different
level, why do you say that,
and how do you feel when you
choose a role that ends up
satisfying you that this one clearly did.
- Well, you know, for me, with
every character that you play
as long as you've reached that,
you've arrived at that place
where you believe is the right
place to be for the character
and if you feel you've done
service to the director,
to yourself, to the author,
then to me, that's a success.
Box Office is kind of,
that's something else,
that's certainly none of my business.
Once I'm wrapped on a film,
it's just to say good bye
to the character, and then move forward.
How ironic is it that, you know,
- You were pumping gas.
- I was pumping gas, most definitely.
Printing T-shirts, and selling
ink pens, and you know,
anything and everything.
Yeah, and then the fact that
you have a 20 year career
of failures, and then
you do a Pirate movie,
and that buys you an island,
the irony of that is pretty...
- Do you think about the times
when things weren't so good a lot?
- Yeah, yeah. But I, you know,
there was a guy that I worked
with many years ago, and
we were talking about
success and money, and all that stuff,
and he told me this one thing, he said,
"Money doesn't change
anybody. Money reveals them."
Same thing with success. And
I believe that wholeheartedly,
I think I've been revealed, I
don't think I haven't changed,
I'm still exactly the same
guy that used to pump gas.
I'm still the guy that was
a mechanic for a minute.
I just happen to have a
weirder job at the moment.
When I was approaching the
character of Willy Wonka,
you know, we all grew up
with the Gene Wilder version,
and it's fantastic. It's fantastic.
But you know, I mean,
why go in that direction.
It's been done. Why repeat. Why?
So I found my own version.
And, my version was,
I kept thinking of
children's television hosts
that scared me.
Because they're unpredictable,
and they have that
very everything was okay.
And it wasn't okay.
But so, I used these children
television hosts sort of ideas
and then the other ingredient
that I thought was what really
found the character, I
thought of George W. Bush.
(audience laughs)
If he were incredibly stoned.
But like not just uncomfortably stoned.
Past what could have been the
uncomfortable paranoia stage
where he just sort of doesn't
know what he's saying.
- Okay, Mad Hatter. Who
is you're Mad Hatter?
- Um, the Mad Hatter was
basically a kind of a
this is real weird.
So my kids had a tutor.
We were on the road, working
you know, so we had this tutor,
her name's Katherine. She's
one of those English people,
very proper, but Katherine
would talk to you,
she had a little bit of
a thing in her voice,
so I sponged her up as much as I could,
because what I loved
about her was she would
sort of talk to you like this, you know,
some people even avert their eyes,
they actually close their eyes
when they're looking at you,
right? You guys have felt that before?
It's weird.
So, I used Katherine, because
when she closed her eyes,
she's looking at you,
and let you know it was
very, very important.
(audience laughs)
She'll probably find this out
tomorrow and there will be
a lawsuit.
There were other things that
I probably should have done,
not from my perspective, I
mean from my point of view
I did the right things.
Every film that I've done, I'm
happy that I made that choice
I don't have any regrets, whatsoever.
But I mean, in terms of
sustaining Box Office
bank ability, I should have
done a few other things
that I didn't do, but I'm
glad I didn't do them.
- Because it wouldn't have been you.
- Yeah, but it would have
been for the wrong reason.
Everything that I've
been lucky enough to do,
I did for the right reason.
You have to realize that
whatever your day is,
whatever you're doing,
whatever your job is,
whatever people think of
you or project you to be,
none of it matters, really,
until you look round,
and see people who are in need.
And I think probably the best
benefit of my job is to help.
To make people smile, who
otherwise wouldn't or couldn't
have a smile on their face.
So yeah, that's my idea.
- I saw Crazy Heart,
and I saw Jeff Bridges
who is obviously a
brilliant brilliant actor,
and is capable of so much.
But what I saw of Jeff
Bridges was so brave,
and so and the only way that
one can arrive at that arena,
is because you have a
director who's brave.
And is open to, like I
said, the idea of chance.
And Scott and I talked
about working together,
I was desperate to work with the guy,
and beyond anything I've ever experienced,
I've never experienced
a director like this.
He doesn't allow the
audience to feel the camera,
to notice the camera, he
makes the camera breath,
as if it's another person.
You never really even notice
these fancy kind of shots.
He would do huge, huge
scenes with a lot of people
in the water, and it was
so freeing, so magnificent
to play that, because you have
this extended period of time
where it's almost like you've got
seven minutes of play almost.
It blew me away. I'm
thinking, "This is this guy's
"third film. It's his third
film. And he's a master,
"like he's a master."
Truly, and if phone books still existed,
I would film the phone book with the man.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed. I
made this video because
wholistic_Nagef asked me
to, so if there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me to profile next,
leave in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
And also really love to know
what did Johnny say that
really left a mark on you,
what was the biggest lesson
that you took from this
that you will immediately
apply to your life or business?
Leave it in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to give a quick
shout out to Jennifer Price.
Jennifer, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
and posting it on Facebook, I
really really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(fast music)
- This is either Madness or brilliant.
- It's remarkable how much
those two tend to coincide.
There's crazy, there's
insanity, there's delirium,
there's, I'm mean, but it's,
to me, it's only madness
and maybe a touch of insanity that,
that one can access.
And, to be aware of it growing up doesn't,
it didn't feel particularly great.
But, I think it's led me
somehow, to where I am today.
I'm not saying that I'm completely mad,
although, I've been accused of that
many times over the years,
but, I don't know. I
hope that people will,
if they do have that tendency,
that they can find a way to embrace it,
and use it to their, not advantage,
let's say, in a, even in a creative sense.
Use it in a creative sense if you can,
but, use that to find your way
to be able to stand on solid ground.
- You've never seen
any of your films ever.
- I tried to see one once.
Because the director asked me to.
My wife, Amber, can
attest to this because her
elbow was very busy that night.
And I was sitting next to her,
and the Director's wife is
here, the Director's here,
I fell asleep 35 times.
(audience laughs)
And I got this.
"Wake up."
- But part of the reason
is being in the moment,
when you're acting, and
after, you don't want to...
- I feel the experience.
I'm happy with the process,
is what I'm interested in.
The process of creating.
The process of exploring.
The process of breaking formula.
The process of dropping
the bottom out of a scene,
because people can get stale.
And I feel that's the wrong place to be.
So, I'm interested in, and
always have been interested in,
trying to avoid what was expected.
And Edward Scissorhands was
certainly the first real
opportunity for me to feel like I
was standing on firm ground.
Cry Baby was important.
Edward Scissorhands was the
first time that I felt Okay.
I'm solid. I can start hacking
through, paving my way.